[Music]
so who's excited about the jake paul
tommy fury fight i'm kind of excited
about it i think it's a good fight i'm
excited for all paul fights let's go me
too can i tell you why i'm kind of
excited about it so the last couple of
fights jake paul he i think he's been
picking his fighters yeah for sure
tyron's a little bit smaller yeah he's a
former mma champion but he's slightly
smaller in stature maybe it doesn't have
so much reach is new to boxing uh the
one before that ben askren kind of like
it not a has been but his boxing is not
his forte no you look like the logo
damn bro right not like a has been i
guess kind of like a loser i guess
you know
hey
a boxer boxer same size same specs or
whatever and he's the little brother
to one of the greatest heavyweights of
all time yeah so i feel like he's
actually like not just picking a fight
that he thinks he could win but i should
challenge him he's talking that [ __ ]
dude and he's fighting the little
brother one of the greatest youtubers of
all time oh yeah that's pretty
interesting
gold versus goat little brother
like it's pretty it's pretty intriguing
to see how the uh do you really think
it's even matching i think so i think
it'll be like closer than the last fight
give us give us the breakdown fight
expert give us the breakdown what you
think well what's tommy good at and
what's jake good at well tommy the the
last fight he had he didn't look that
good against a guy who isn't really a
good boxer and a good striker so
did he win he did win but a lot of
people were like i think jake paul's
gonna beat this guy up oh [ __ ] really
yeah and i kind of think tommy fury
might win but now i'm starting to lean
towards jake paul actually going to beat
him up that's how i feel i don't know
much about boxing but i
mma follow a little bit and i've heard a
lot of mma guys obviously tap into these
conversations because it's interesting a
lot of guys say like we got to stop
looking at jake paul like a youtuber and
like kind of like a badass amateur he's
been he bro honestly he's better than
logan dude like when i remember when i
saw them both coming up and fighting i
was thinking like jake paul could
probably knock out logan paul he
practices more he's a better boxer than
logan was logan a better wrestler is
that why you say that why why would you
think logan's better well because he
started first like he started boxing
first and he had he's bigger exactly
because i thought i heard logan is a
better wrestler in high school oh
probably yeah logan plays with his
pokemon cards a lot so he can't just
busy we got other hobbies
but he's capable of evolving into a more
mature pokemon and also if you compare
if you compare logan paul and jake
paul's like
records of who they fought yeah jake
paul has the cooler jake paul isn't lost
right yeah he has a cooler name bigger
names did they do wasn't there a moment
in youtube uh where they hated each
other oh really i thought so i thought i
saw a documentary where they didn't like
each other i think it was just a fake
thing
because i would like if they fought each
other but they were angry have you guys
heard the clause though i think there
was a clause in the contract that's what
we're about to talk about right now
with jake paul and tyrone woodley that
is tyron woodley isn't allowed to knock
jake paul out is that was that true is
that confirmed how do you do how do you
keep from knocking someone out you just
no it's in the contract i've heard that
too and then it'll be an automatic
dequeue so for example
when we watch the tyson versus uh roy
jones jr one it's an exhibition fight
and it's no knockout yeah if you get if
you if there's a knockout it's
definitely penalized the other one is
steroids i heard uh at that time some of
them you could test let me don't i heard
this last one they didn't test yeah the
woodley one hey you think jake paul's on
a sauce what's your expert opinion on
that since i'm the steroid doctor of the
group ah yes yes
i've just been in fitness a long time
i would love some um we should do that
next it's definitely possible that
uh woodley and jake were taking
something something uh and also in like
would they too i think it's definitely
possible so this is gonna be uh i'm not
accusing either of them because neither
of them blaringly trust me if it was
blaring i'd be like yeah they problem so
so there's gonna be a no uh steroid
fight i don't know about the next one
but the last one i heard there and who
knows right i'm not there
are they going to check for it for this
one i heard last one they didn't um so i
assume this one they would maybe not and
also when it comes to mma and more
skilled sports even like basketball or
something there's a lot of compounds you
could take that are peds um steroid just
means like fake hormone um
and when we think you're like dude
you're going to look like mark maguire
and your head's going to grow but
there's a lot of little lance armstrong
on a ped you can take a lot of little
things that can improve your performance
that are illegal um so they can easily
be on some epo [ __ ] yeah i use
ashwagandha that makes your dick real
big oh cool
i need ten of those yeah i need some of
that too so so i don't want a big dick
it's been a great promotion the jake
paul has reportedly written a whole heap
of different strange clauses into this
contract as well really the recent
announced fight with tommy fury the
contracts dictate everything there's
like that's annoying glove ounce size
round how many rounds horse hair
the pow leather yeah the the material of
the gloves and he just leans it towards
him because he brings in the money yeah
can jake paul hit
knock him out though like does it work
both ways both oh actually i don't know
i don't know as a not fan how do you
explain that to the audience if you if
they see a knockout they're like okay
that guy just won and then like no he
didn't he lost yeah yeah like [ __ ] that
that'll never wash i think the intention
is to never even get there well i bet
you it's written in that you don't get
your money so woodley would never knock
him out yeah so i think that's why jake
paul can also i mean i don't know if
that the clause is true or not but
that's why but that's why jake paul can
like his his go-to phrase is like this
is the biggest fight of your career
biggest purse of your career and i think
it is like you want 800 g's yeah you
can't knock me out at this point why
don't we just go [ __ ] watch wwe again
see that's the thing right i'd rather
watch stone cold the rock at least
they're funny because the illusion of a
real fight is what people but that's
what started with the wwe people used to
think that [ __ ] was real we're heading
right there
it's real to me damn it it's real to me
damn
so one of the giant rumors that was just
going around that just actually got
confirmed is not true in the contract
but this was pretty [ __ ] funny when i
read it is that because and it's also
because after the last fight with tyrone
will be right didn't you have to get a
tattoo of yeah
was that fake the tattoo kind of looked
fake it kind of it didn't get like i
think you got a real one okay it wasn't
a tattoo
i just thought one video in the attack
kind of looked fake yeah it looked like
sharpie or something i don't think i
would do a nice looking tab of that i'd
probably go get a present out of it
anyway yeah you get something like
scripture uh font so do you read it
brand new tats do look fake though
sometimes they're sharp and this one it
says that uh um there are things such as
additional money to be paid specifically
from jake paul's purse so if fury wins
paul actually has to like give him an
extra hundred thousand dollars out of
his own wallet or some [ __ ] like that um
and then if uh
if paul wins
then uh this was a rumor but tommy fury
had to change his last name legally to
tommy fumbles
that's so stupid i love ideas
i think if you think you're a badass you
do yeah that's true
is that he said paul's team is being
awkward the contract's been bizarre it
was going to go through uh and what they
put in the contract with what they put
in the contract we'd be here all day
i've said yes to everything yes yes yes
do what you've got to do because i know
jake paul can't beat tommy no matter
what he does this is his manager right
wow
tommy's manager yeah hey then double
down dude you don't need fumbles is a
little low for the first it says paul
himself shared a few shots of the
contract on his social media accounts
including text that reads if fury's
declared the winner of the ballot paul
hereby agrees to pay fury five hundred
thousand dollars directly from paul's
person's additional fighter bonus
however
if paul's declared the winner of the
ballot fury hereby agrees to one
commence within 30 days of the
conclusion of the bout an application
process with the royal courts of justice
in the uk to obtain a deed poll legally
changing fury's name to tommy fumbles
and two change within 24 hours of the
bout all of his social media accounts to
reflect the name
and three immediately after about
utilizing any tommy fumbles in all forms
of media dude if you really think you're
gonna win you're like hey dude i'll
change my name to tommy [ __ ] holes
and i'm saying if you really think
you're gonna win you're putting [ __ ]
holes versus 500k every time yeah well
part of it is he's still getting paid
yeah for the other guy i'm sure he's
thinking he's like do i even say yes
cause this [ __ ] that i'm gonna
fight even propose this like part of it
is like i'm not gonna sign the [ __ ] [ __ ]
jake paul like
i respect his negotiating skills that's
so funny because 500 g's to him is
nothing right so he's giving something
where if the other person loses this guy
loses all credibility his manhood
everything for him if he loses he's like
oh here's a couple quarters yeah that's
true so he's really setting it up in his
favor and i think he's he could be like
the joker of boxing and the stakes are
raised now it's entertaining now we want
to watch it the fact that tyron woodley
got a tattoo
for the sake of trying to get a rematch
is crazy yeah so because of the knockout
thing and like he can't win yeah that's
why i felt the tat was even more fake
yeah i'm like oh it's all just part of
this year-long marketing skill it could
be yeah if you could guarantee me the
the fight's [ __ ] real yeah and
everything go down i'm down for all this
so yeah yeah i want tommy [ __ ] hole yeah
i want to watch him
because then it does it really does feel
like the other day we're all still going
to watch it anyway right [ __ ] yeah i am
that's what i'm saying like there's
nothing else on dude
what am i going to watch that's true
some of this [ __ ] they're like hey you
guys gotta check out the new cop show
and i'm like dude they have a new cop
show there's always new cop shows dude i
was like
they say they say um
in a follow-up article though just to
make sure our followers know that it's a
rumor or maybe it's not uh said that no
it's not in the contract the promoter
warren says it's not a contract i'll
tell you what i think jake paul is a
really good promoter he's very good
promoter and he's fun there's no doubt
about it it's going to be a lot of fun
these two are obviously going to get at
each other it's going to be a fun
promotion there's no doubt and the
reason why i think he's the joker is in
this sport of mma and boxing all that
stuff everyone's trying to be extra
macho right yeah so we're trying to be
extra macho but when you have a guy
that's the clown and he's like because
you're like okay yeah i'll cut my
[ __ ] leg off if i lose [ __ ] yeah no
no you're going to wear a [ __ ] pink
bandana wait what like you should kind
of just see all the super macho guys
kind of malfunction what do you mean
last name to fumbles because it's stuff
that they're not even considering yeah
like what what that's why i've said the
whole time before it was cool that this
is good for the sport i've said it the
whole time people you know the david
sews on the table they're like this is
disrespectful to the [ __ ] sport oh
[ __ ] off but you need a little bit of
that you need it but david's so super
credible what that says
i got love sandwiches right yeah david
sandwiches
david [ __ ] hole
you